House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
That's Fire And Blood volume 1. The yet unreleased
Fire And Blood volume 2 will continue from
where part 1 ended, with Rhaenyra Targaryen's
son Aegon lll's reign and will cover Blackyre
rebellions, war with Dorne and go all the
way to the Mad King and Robert's Rebellion
that ended Targaryen dynasty.
Robert's Rebellion, also known as the War
of the Usurper, was a rebellion against House
Targaryen, primarily instigated by Eddard
Stark, Jon Arryn, and Robert Baratheon, for
whom it's named.
It lasted "close to a year" and resulted in
the end of the Targaryen dynasty in the Seven
Kingdoms.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
One of the main characters from this time
period was Rhaegar Targaryen.
Prince Rhaegar Targaryen, the last Prince
of Dragonstone,
was the eldest son and heir to King Aerys
II Targaryen,
the Mad King by his sister-wife Queen Rhaella
Targaryen.
Having features of old Valyrian, Rhaegar had
deep purple eyes and silver-blond hair.
As a child he read obsessively, to the point
that jests were made about his habits.
He became a noted warrior later in life, although
he did not initially seem inclined to martial
habits. However, apparently by something he
had read, Rhaegar became motivated to become
a warrior.
Rhaegar was the older brother of Viserys and
Daenerys Targaryen
and husband of Elia Martell, with whom he
had two children, Rhaenys and Aegon.
He also fathered Jon Snow with Lyanna Stark,
whom he secretly married
following an annulment from Elia.
Aerys II's reign began with great promise,
but as years passed, he slid deeper and deeper
into insanity and paranoia. The shift was
gradual and he frequently recovered: by the
time it became severe,
Prince Rhaegar already showed such great promise
as the future heir to the throne that most
were willing to endure Aerys's eccentricities,
intending to wait out the remainder of his
reign until Rhaegar succeeded him.
Rhaegar was brave, kind, and wise and most
looked forward to the golden era that would
assuredly begin when he would ascend to the
throne. Greatly troubled by Aerys II's growing
insanity,
Rhaegar was torn between whether to act against
him or not,
but could not bring himself to turn against
his own father.
At court, there was growing tension between
factions loyal to the king and to the prince.
Grand Maester Pycelle dispatched a letter
to the Citadel,
writing that tensions and division at court
strongly resembled those before the Dance
of the Dragons.
Pycelle was fearful a Targaryen civil war
would break out
unless some accord could be reached that would
satisfy both factions.
Like the rest of the realm, Rhaegar hoped
to simply wait out the rest of his father's
reign,
and that his bouts of insanity would remain
manageable by his courtiers.
Rhaegar had good reason to think that the
small council could keep the realm together
despite his father's madness, as it was very
capably led by Tywin Lannister,
who served as Aerys's Hand for nearly twenty
years. Tywin was not only able to keep Aerys
from tearing the realm apart, but managed
royal affairs so well, that he brought two
decades of peace and plenty for Westeros,
to the point that most people throughout the
realm were unaware of the king's madness until
the final years of his reign.
Many assumed that in reward for Tywin's long
and distinguished service as Aerys's chief
advisor,
the bond between the Targaryens and Lannisters
would eventually be solidified with a marriage-alliance
between Prince Rhaegar and Tywin's daughter
Cersei. Yet Aerys surprisingly spurned the
match,
saying that Tywin was still just a servant
and should not try to elevate his family above
its station,
as such a match was beneath Rhaegar.
Aerys instead agreed to an arranged marriage
between Rhaegar and Elia Martell,
a princess from Dorne, daughter of the ruling
Princess of Dorne
(who was a distant cousin of the royal line
through intermarriage a century before).
Rhaegar and Elia's marriage was happy according
to all accounts.
Rhaegar and Elia had two children: a daughter
named Rhaenys, and then a son named Aegon.
Maester Aemon, whom Rhaegar corresponded via
raven messages,
remembers that Rhaegar believed his child
Aegon to be the prince that was promised.
A few years later, the Great Tourney at Harrenhal
was held and all the prominent lords of Westeros
assembled. During the feast, Rhaegar played
a song on his harp so beautiful and sorrowful
that it moved even the wild she-wolf Lyanna
Stark to tears. The exact events that happened
in private are unknown, but the public events
at the tourney's final joust are known to
all: Rhaegar won.
During the great tourney at Harrenhal, Rhaegar
seemed unstoppable
and defeated even Ser Arthur Dayne. Taking
the winter rose crown for the queen of love
and beauty,
he revealed his interest in Lyanna Stark by
passing over his wife, Princess Elia of Dorne,
and setting it in Lyanna's lap. Eddard Stark
later recalled that moment as "when all the
smiles died".
The next year, Rhaegar seemingly kidnapped
Lyanna, for reasons unknown.
This act ultimately triggered Robert's Rebellion
and the downfall of the Targaryen dynasty.
Unknown to all, Lyanna had actually desired
to leave with Rhaegar, and they ran off together
to the Red Mountains of Dorne. They stayed
at a relatively small castle Rhaegar named
the Tower of Joy.
Rhaegar arranged for the High Septon to grant
him an annulment from his marriage to Elia
Martell,
then personally officiate his secret marriage
to Lyanna the same day.
Lyanna's eldest brother Brandon then rode
to King's Landing
to demand the return of his sister and the
death of Rhaegar.
King Aerys imprisoned him, and when Rickard
Stark went south to ransom his son,
he was imprisoned as well. The Mad King then
brutally executed both of them
by burning Lord Rickard alive with wildfire
in front of the Iron Throne
and baiting Brandon into strangling himself
to death in an effort to save his father.
Afterward, King Aerys demanded Jon Arryn to
send him the heads of Eddard Stark and Robert
Baratheon.
Jon Arryn refused, and instead, raised his
banners in revolt.
Eddard Stark and Lyanna's betrothed, Robert
Baratheon, joined him to overthrow the Targaryen
dynasty. This war became known as Robert's
Rebellion, or the "War of the Usurper" to
Targaryen loyalists. To the confusion of many,
Rhaegar's location remained unknown during
most of the war, which lasted about a year:
as Robert Baratheon's rebel army fought its
way up from Storm's End
through the Reach and the Riverlands, and
then up to the Trident, Rhaegar was nowhere
to be seen.
Rhaegar then suddenly returned to the royal
court at King's Landing to lead the crown's
armies.
Both sides now mobilized the full might of
their forces: Robert led his rebel army south
(composed of Baratheon, Stark, Tully, and
Arryn forces) while Rhaegar led the royal
army north to meet him (composed of the Targaryen
armies raised from the Crownlands, supplemented
by another 10,000 from Dorne). Rhaegar owned
night-black plate armor, with the three-headed
dragon of House Targaryen decorated in rubies
on its breastplate, and underneath the plate
he wore golden ringmail.
Rhaegar decorated his helm with gold, orange,
and red silken streamers resembling flames.
Accompanying Rhaegar were two of the Kingsguard,
Barristan Selmy and Lewyn Martell (uncle of
Rhaegar's wife Elia). On the way, Rhaegar
privately confided to Barristan that after
they won,
there would be "many changes" at the royal
court upon his return - alluding that he intended
to depose his father for his crimes and instability,
and try to restore peace with the Great Houses
of the realm.
Rhaegar and Robert's forces finally clashed
at the climactic Battle of the Trident,
at the crossing of the Kingsroad over the
river (not far from the Inn at the Crossroads).
Rhaegar's army was fresh and slightly larger,
but Robert's was more battle-hardened,
and they slowly gained ground.
Rhaegar and Robert spotted each other across
the battlefield and rode out to fight,
resulting in a legendary duel as the battle
dragged on around them.
Rhaegar, despite wounding Robert, was struck
down with a massive blow from Robert's warhammer,
which scattered the rubies encrusted in Rhaegar's
armor into the water.
With their leader killed, the Targaryen army
collapsed, and the rebels were victorious.
With Rhaegar's death, the Targaryen cause
was doomed: most of their supporters had been
fighting for Rhaegar, not the Mad King, so
after he died most either surrendered or switched
sides.
Soon after Rhaegar's death, most of his family
followed to an early grave.
The first was his first wife Elia and their
children when they were brutally killed by
Ser Gregor Clegane during the Sack of King's
Landing.
Meanwhile, Jaime Lannister killed Rhaegar's
father, King Aerys, to prevent the wildfire
plot.
Shortly before the sack, Rhaegar's heavily
pregnant mother Queen Rhaella had been sent
to safety on Dragonstone island, along with
his younger brother Viserys.
Not long after they arrived, however, Rhaella
died giving birth to Rhaegar's posthumous
younger sister, Daenerys Targaryen.
Viserys and his newborn sister then fled into
exile in the Free Cities, across the Narrow
Sea,
before Robert's soldiers could arrive on the
island. Lyanna Stark did not survive much
longer than Rhaegar either: she died from
childbirth, after having given birth to her
son,Rhaegar's last child and heir. With her
last breath, Lyanna told Eddard of her secret
marriage to Rhaegar,
and that their son's name was "Aegon Targaryen".
Ultimately, Rhaegar still remains a controversial
figure as his star-crossed romance with Lyanna
Stark inadvertently led
to his insane father sparking a war with half
of the Seven Kingdoms.
Thousands died due to Rhaegar's actions (or
inaction),
ending in his death, the overthrow and exile
of what was left of his family,
and (indirectly) resulted in the murder of
Elia and their two children together.
What could have possibly motivated Rhaegar
to not only elope with Lyanna,
but fight a war to keep their marriage a secret,
remains unknown.
Rhaegar valued his forthcoming child with
Lyanna so much
that he even left champions of his Kingsguard
behind in Dorne to defend her –
living legends who could have tipped the balance
if they had fought by his side at the Battle
of the Trident. Perhaps it was his obsession
with Azor Ahai prophecy, believing his son
Aegon, who we know as Jon Snow, was the Prince
that was Promised. There's so much we need
to learn.
How did Rhaegar and Lyanna fall in love and
why did they decide to run away.
What was that important to them to leave without
an explanation, making it seem like he kidnapped
her which put the Seven Kingdoms into the
state of chaos which started the rebellion
that ended the Targaryen dynasty. But that's
all we have for now, questions without certain
answers,
questions which the Game of Thrones prequel
about history of House Targaryen,
House of the Dragon, will answer.
Thank you so much for watching, I hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please give
it a big thumbs up and I hope to see you in
the next one.
Peace!